hey you guys doing another flickers of
fear for y'all today it's my little
movie review show hate to tell you but
we're doing another arty farting today
but that's kind of one of the reasons
that i started doing this little
offshoot show just so i could do like
some arty farty stuff and you know what
i mean
so i dig that kind of stuff it's you
know so whatever but uh yeah so this is
one that has actually been on my watch
list for [ __ ] years because i keep
seeing it i kept seeing it come up on
you know best horror movies best vampire
movies that kind of stuff and i'm just
like yeah man i really need to get
around to watching that especially
because it's all over like the different
streaming services you got i watched it
on shutter actually uh but i think it
was on netflix i don't know if it is
anymore uh but it's on amazon prime
actually now i think you can as of this
recording at least i think you can watch
it on 2b for free so there's absolutely
no excuse if you wanted to see this one
now it's pretty much everywhere and this
is the movie that came out in 2014
and it's called a girl walks home alone
at night this was the debut feature film
of anna lilyamerpore
who uh since then has gone on i think
she's made a couple movies since then
one of which was called the bad batch
which uh i've actually heard quite a bit
about but i haven't gotten around to
seeing i think it's kind of like a
cannibal love story type of situation uh
so i'll probably watch that one as well
and i think she's made a couple other
ones uh too since then this movie in
particular she had made a short film
that was called the same thing and uh
she i guess it kind of got around and
she started an indiegogo campaign back
in 2012 or 2013 uh to get the money to
expand this into a feature film and she
was successful in doing that so um you
know this film was it's very very low
budget
but honestly the cinematography in it is
so gorgeous
that
you i mean i really didn't notice like
because when i looked at how much she i
think she asked like in the original
indiegogo campaign i think she asked for
like 55 000
and she got like over that like i think
she got 56 000 or 57 000 and ended up
shooting it and
this is like i said you don't need a lot
of bells and whistles if you have like a
cool concept and you have
people that know what they're doing like
behind the camera because like i said
one of the best things about this movie
is the cinematography it is beautiful
it's like it's black and white and it
just it looks [ __ ] gorgeous it's one
of the most beautiful movies uh that
came out like in the last 20 years
easily it's just like a gorgeous looking
movie and it's kind of sad that it
didn't really get any
awards for the cinematography one of my
other favorite things about this is
actually the score the soundtrack and
the sound design
it's very interesting because it has a
lot of kind of like 80s influenced kind
of indie rock pop type stuff in it too
but then it also kind of has a little
bit of like a western kind of vibe to it
which
is interesting because so i guess like
anna lily amrapore
she um is
iranian but she was actually born in the
uk she was born in england and she ended
up moving to i think florida actually
miami florida with her family when she
was a kid and then they moved out to
california where she went to high school
and subsequently to college so she has a
very interesting
and she's always kind of been into i
think she was uh she was in a band for a
while like she sang and played bass in a
band and she works as a dj also so she's
really really into music and she said
that when she first came to the united
states she was very struck by all the
kind of american pop music and the
culture and everything like that um so i
kind of feel like this movie
was a really kind of personal thing for
her because she said that she kind of
took everything that she loved and was
obsessed with and put it all into this
one movie now like i said this is
i'm not gonna lie to you this is a very
arty movie uh so if you're not into that
then you will probably not dig it like
might you might just think it's boring
or nothing happens or whatever like
stuff does happen in it but it's not
it's it's kind of like
i'm gonna give you i'm gonna throw out
some movies that this reminded me of
and some of this stuff is stuff that she
said were like big influences on her uh
she was really into she's basically
called this like the love child of david
lynch and sergio leone uh she really
likes all the old spaghetti westerns so
this one has a very kind of like man
with no name kind of vibe to it you know
with the score and just kind of the way
the character is also in the sound
design and stuff like that uh gives a
very early lynch like a racer head type
of vibe has that kind of going on too uh
probably what this reminded me of the
most was jim jarmusch stranger than
paradise uh for sure uh only levers left
alive which i covered not too long ago
this is kind of like that kind of thing
and also as far as vampire films go this
is very much in the same vein as
something like
uh let the right one in or the addiction
with lily taylor if anybody remembers
that one that was actually a good one i
think shutter just added that i'll have
to do that one too uh there was one
called nadia that i think had
christopher walken in it if i'm not
mistaken uh so it kind of gives me that
sort of vibe too so it's a vampire film
but
it's also it has horror elements but
it's also mostly kind of like well i
don't even know mostly it's almost i
don't want to say pastiche because that
sounds like i'm denigrating it and it's
but but i just kind of mean it's this
sort of collage maybe that's like a
better like less loaded word it's kind
of like a collage of all of these
influences that she really is into so
it's almost kind of like it's a horror
movie but it's also kind of like a
western and it's all also kind of like a
50s
uh homage to like a james dean type of
movie and it also has like a lot of
romance to it so it doesn't really fit
comfortably in one genre but i think
that's what's kind of cool about it
actually because
it's just one of those i mean for a
first feature
to
kind of i guess kind of have the
confidence to make something like this
that
like i said can't really be slotted into
any one genre and it just kind of like
mixes up genres but in a really
interesting kind of way so i think
that's like a really cool uh thing that
she did uh also she's really into uh
graphic novels um which
she said that she got a lot of the ideas
for the look of this because like i said
the cinematography that's the the black
and white cinematography is just
beautiful that she got that from
graphic novels comic books and actually
the fictional city that's in in the
movie which is called bad city i'm
pretty sure that she meant that as like
an homage to frank miller uh sin city so
there's that as well um also if you have
read the graphic novel persepolis i
believe they made an animated film out
of it um although
i don't remember if i've seen it i read
the graphic novel but i don't think i
saw the thing you'll kind of get that
kind of vibe too
so if any of that sounds like
like your cup of tea like if any of
those movies i mentioned you know if you
like any of those or you like that kind
of vibe then you will probably really
really dig this
so what this movie is about like i said
essentially it's kind of like a vampire
story but there's a bunch of other stuff
going on too
so at the beginning of the movie were
introduced um oh and i should say too
that even though this movie is set in a
fictional iranian city it's supposed to
be set in iran but not and it's in
persian or farsi if you prefer but it
was actually shot in taft california
so that's actually not iran but it's
supposed to be that but you know what i
mean it's it's interesting because like
i said it's this kind of cross-cultural
collage which kind of like brings up a
lot of interesting uh sort of things
that you can sort of bring to it so uh
so there's this young guy who's very uh
james deanie looking he's got the white
t-shirt and the jeans and the kind of
pompadouri kind of hair
and uh he is he works as like he's like
a gardener a landscaper just like a
like a handyman type dude and he doesn't
have a lot of money but he works for
kind of wealthy people
and he has worked really hard and has
saved up all this money
to buy
this gorgeous um like classic car i
can't remember what kind of car it is
sorry i'm not like really a car person
but you know it's also like i said it's
a very james deaney type situation and
this is kind of like you know this place
is called bad city and so it's this kind
of shitty you know there's like oil
derricks and there's all kind of like
rundown kind of [ __ ] everywhere and uh
you know there's drug dealers and
prostitutes and so it's like a bad place
it seems like his car is kind of like
the one thing he saved up all this money
and he's really really proud of it
because that's like the one thing that
he has that's awesome now he lives with
his dad hussein
who is a heroin addict now what ends up
happening with this is that there's a
drug dealer who i guess has been selling
the dad the heroine
and his name is saeed
and i guess like since the dad has been
like you know taking all this heroin
like on the
like on credit i guess and so it's like
so he owes said all this money
and uh obviously the dad doesn't have
any money because he's kind of like he's
old and he kind of like can't do
anything he just kind of lays around
does heroin all the time uh much to uh a
rushed of if i didn't say arash is the
uh james deeney guy uh much to arash's
chagrin who's out there working his ass
off and dad's just taking all his money
or whatever so this drug dealer comes
and basically says well your dad owes me
all this money
so i'm gonna take your car
so
arash obviously is very very upset about
this and he ends up doing kind of a bad
thing but kind of an understandable
thing where he goes to um the house of
this one young woman that he works for
like this one wealthy woman and uh while
she's not looking he steals a pair of
like diamond earrings or like really
expensive earrings like trying to get
some of the money back or trying to like
trade it back for the car now syed the
drug dealer then we're kind of following
him and he's just kind of these he he
looks essentially like exactly like what
you'd expect like a drug dealer look
like i guess
he's just kind of like he's got like the
bleached hair and he's got like tattoos
on his neck and all that kind of stuff
so he's walking around
and he sees uh this girl now this girl
the girl that walks home alone at night
is never given a name she's just the
girl
and she is wearing like a black uh chad
or just like over her whole thing and uh
but she's wearing makeup though she has
like i you know it's like eyeliner and
lipstick and stuff and i have to say
that that actress whose name is sheila
band is
beautiful she is just like and she's
like like perfect for this because she
has this really like gorgeous she's like
this otherworldly kind of beauty to her
and uh so she just i mean she looks so
great she's got such a great face
uh but yeah so she's kind of just
standing there sort of creepily and uh
so saeed i guess he thinks that she's a
hooker
and you know so he's like oh okay i'm
down with this let's go back to my place
and he's trying to be all cool like
putting the techno music on and putting
out some lines of coke and all this
other stuff and she's just kind of
standing there staring at him and then
you're like huh i wonder what this is
all about and then she kind of like gets
all up in his face and then like little
fangs pop out good joke uh and she bites
his finger off
and then ends up killing him
so uh so yeah so that happens
so
she's going around at night like i said
she can go around by herself at night
because she's a vampire and so anybody
[ __ ] with her then she's just gonna do
it now it's interesting because in this
she she's a vampire but she still has
like some humanity to her seemingly
because she doesn't just like
attack people at random she seems to
kind of target
bad people largely although you can tell
that when she's like meets good people
she's still kind of like tempted because
you know blood and everything but she
seems like able to like like i said much
like uh let the right one in or
something like that and there is like a
a big like romance aspect to this movie
as well so she kills uh saeed the drug
dealer and kind of just leaves him there
fingerless and dead and so then um arash
happens to come to the drug dealer's
house because he's like hey i got these
diamond earrings you know he wants to
trade it back to get his car back and
then uh he finds his ass like dead in
there and he's like oh well [ __ ] um well
i'm just gonna take all this money and
these drugs and i'm gonna quit my job
and just like you know have all this
money and be a drug dealer so you know
again understandable so uh later on he
actually ends up going to this costume
party and he's dressed up like dracula
and while he's at the party he's like
talking to these other uh girls that he
knows
and because he stole all the drugs from
uh the from the drug dealer
he's like oh i'm just gonna take some of
this ecstasy so he does that and when he
leaves the party he's just kind of like
wandering around in the street going
like wow man you know what i mean like
just looking at the lights and
everything
so this happened and like i said arash
even though yes he stole earrings yes he
stole a bunch of money and you know and
drugs and stuff and he's like oh i'm a
drug dealer now but it's like he's still
a good guy like you can tell he's a good
guy and you know he's kind of got [ __ ]
over by life his dad's kind of useless
and you know kind of takes all his money
and just lays there doing drugs so it's
like you know and like i said he seems
like a good dude so it's like even
though he does do some like stuff that
maybe
is questionable he still comes across as
like a nice man who's just like doing
what he's got to do in this kind of like
[ __ ] uh place that they live
so he's wandering around in the street
and then you see
[Music]
the girl
and she's kind of like looking at him
and at first you're kind of like because
you've spent like quite a bit of this
movie so far with arash and he's like i
said he's a good dude and you're just
kind of like oh man like you kind of
think that the girl's gonna kill him
right but
apparently it's not that she's kind of
like fascinated by it maybe because he's
dressed like dracula maybe because
she can tell that he's a nice person but
she just kind of gets interested in him
and he just kind of like he's kind of
like whacked out of his mind on ecstasy
or whatever but she kind of gets him
back to her apartment or her she has
this kind of like basement studio that
she lives in and it's all covered with
like posters she's got posters like
madonna and like the bee gees and stuff
like that back there and she's uh when
she's back at her house she kind of
wears this kind of very new wavy looking
like black and white striped shirt very
stylish uh so the and then there's this
kind of long scene where she puts um
this song on it's this great song man
it's called uh i think it's called death
by the white lies
and she puts that on and in the movie
like it's pretty much the whole song
plays
while the two of them are kind of like
you know kind of swaying around each
other and stuff and like i said it's
kind of it's kind of cool because it's
like nothing they don't really talk or
anything like that but
it's almost like you're afraid that
something's gonna happen because it's
like you still don't know because he's
kind of going back with his neck like
that you still don't know
you haven't seen enough of the girl to
know if she's just like a monster
and she's just like seducing because she
kind of did the same thing to saeed when
she picked him up she was just kind of
like pretending that she was all you
know you know she had makeup on and she
was kind of pretending to be seductive
and everything and then she kind of ate
him um so you're kind of thinking that
maybe the same thing is going to happen
here but it doesn't happen so she almost
kind of like feels this kind of like
affinity with him and i think that um i
was reading some interviews with uh
analytica
anna lily amberpoor
about this and she said that she
actually wrote this story because
she was kind of like lonely so she kind
of i guess you know i'm maybe this is
not what she meant but she seems
she seems to like these kind of lonely
marginalized characters that are kind of
just like wandering around in the night
and are not really like don't fit in
anywhere so i think that maybe she kind
of in some way
saw herself in
uh the girl you know in the vampire
character i will note too that that anna
lily amapor is also like a real big
skateboarder and so whenever you see the
girl the vampire skateboarding in this
because there's a great scene of her
like uh skateboarding down the street at
night with her with her chat or kind of
flying out around like it's like [ __ ]
batwings and stuff that was actually
anna lilly herself um because she's
rolling to skateboarding so like i said
oh i forgot to say too that another big
influence on this is not sparachi the
original one and i think that she even
had like all of the actors and stuff
like that watch
nosferatu as well as a bunch of
spaghetti westerns like before they did
this movie so they could kind of get an
idea of where she was going because i
kind of the cinematography too like it's
kind of really like soft and dark around
the edges
almost kind of like an homage to like
old silent films so it really does kind
of have that but it's very very crisp
like in the middle but in the it kind of
has these soft blacks around the outside
and it's like really really cool looking
so it's almost kind of like her
and arash
sort of develop like i said this kind of
affinity and she kind of tries to tell
him look i'm bad i'm a monster
and but he seems like kind of okay with
it so they sort of like i said much like
like let the right one in they kind of
like develop this sort of relationship
with one another and even though he
doesn't really find out until later like
what she is and you know what she's done
but it's almost kind of like he accepts
her the way she is and she's fascinated
by him because
even though she's a monster he like
approaches her with
with sympathy and it's kind of a thing
like he there's this one scene where he
just like buys her a hamburger and she
doesn't really eat it because obviously
she's a vampire and i guess they don't
eat hamburgers but then he gives her the
earrings that he stole
and she doesn't have her ears pierced so
he so he like pierces her ears like she
asks them to pierce them so it's like
this really kind of like sweet sort of
scene like i said it's it's almost kind
of like a romance in a sense so uh what
ends up happening then there's also this
other um
prostitute named ati
who uh shaid the drug dealer had been
real shitty to earlier
and so basically what um what the girl
ends up doing is like getting a bunch of
money from arash who had taken all the
money from saeed's apartment and
actually ends up giving the money to the
prostitute because i guess again saeed
had been going to ati for a long time
and hadn't really been paying her so i
guess so so the girl almost kind of like
you know goes like here's your money
you know and then she doesn't eat her so
it's fine now what ends up happening
though is that
hussein um arash's dad
is like i said really [ __ ] up on
heroin and he has this kind of mental
breakdown where
he thinks that there's that arash has
this cat i love this cat by the way the
cat that's in this movie is like super
super cute
and
i heard i don't know if this is true or
not but i was saw another review of this
that said that the cat actually wasn't
originally in the script
but when the director like just saw this
cat or was somebody's cat that she knew
was or it was like an actor cat i don't
know if it was an actor cat she said
this cat was just so awesome like
personality-wise like we really have to
put this cat in the movie and i really
really liked it the cats in the movie
because if see every time i'm i've
watched so many horror movies now that
whenever i see a cat
or a dog too but i mean i'm more a cat
person but yeah anytime i see a dog too
at the beginning of a horror movie i
always get really nervous because i'm
like oh man something bad's gonna happen
to that cat and i'm gonna be really
really upset about it and indeed i did
have that because the cat like turns up
right at the very beginning like the
first time you meet arash like in the um
very first scene
he picks up the cat i think it's like a
white and ginger it's a black and white
movie so it's hard to tell but it looks
like a white and ginger cat and and he
picks it up and kind of carries it
around and there's like a really tense
scene where
saeed the drug dealer has come over to
like arash in his dad's house and he
picks up the cat and he's like kind of
doing and i'm just like oh my god if you
do something to that cat i'd be so so
upset but it's like he does the cat
lives so it's like it's fine don't don't
get upset because i was like so relieved
i was like the whole movie i was just
like please don't let because that cat
is so cute and the cat is so awesome and
i really don't want anything bad to
happen to it but yeah so there's another
scene too where hossein
he's all [ __ ] up on heroin and he gets
this he has this kind of like flip out
where
he thinks that the cat has his dead
wife's eyes and is like looking at him
and like judging him and stuff which i
get that because cats do have like the
very judgy kind of like
kind of look so i can see that but
obviously
you know that's crazy like what he's
saying but he starts flipping out about
it and he's like knocking [ __ ] over and
everything arash comes home and is like
what the [ __ ] is your problem and
basically arash probably rightfully so
um kicks his dad at the house he's like
here take the drugs that i stole take
this money and just get out of here like
get out of my life and uh sadly this is
the one time that i didn't like a rush
because he said take the cat with you
now it's a rash's cat so i don't know
why he would say that but he's like just
take all the money and drugs just get
out of my life take the cat with you now
what ends up happening after that though
is that
arash's dad hossein goes to ati the
prostitute
and um you know is trying to get some
lovin or whatever and then like the girl
shows up
and she lets ati go but she ends up
killing hossein the dad
now
this um kind of puts her in a little bit
of an awkward position obviously because
that's arash's dad although he was kind
of like useless and arash did throw him
out
so there's that whole situation but she
does kill him and like drink his blood
and everything and then her and ati the
prostitute they basically just take the
body and like dump it in a ditch
someplace um because like i said this
place is called bad city so there's no
there's no law enforcement there's no
nothing like that it's kind of it's like
i said it's kind of supposed to be like
a western where you can just do all this
stuff and dump bodies wherever and like
nobody because nobody ever i don't think
anybody ever does anything about saeed's
body either which she just kind of like
left in his apartment
so no one's like super worried about
anything like i said this is a very low
budget film so it's a very small cast so
obviously they're not going to have hey
let's call the cops you know it's you
know this is almost kind of like a dream
like you know it's a city that doesn't
exist so it's almost kind of like this
weird dream like you know liminal kind
of uh area
so basically what ends up happening is
that the girl you know after they
dispose of hussein's body like she takes
the cat with her
and her having the cat well actually
arash sees his dad's body like in the
ditch or whatever and then he notices
that the girl has the has his cat so he
realizes oh my gosh like she killed my
dad
and then so they kind of both get in the
car and it's like very tense the car the
cat's kind of sitting in the middle like
looking like that and he has to like
pull over and get out and he's like he
can't decide because like you know what
am i gonna do am i gonna you know i
don't know if he's thinking about like
killing her because of what she did or
if he's just gonna accept it
and uh in the end he actually does
accept it and they just kind of like go
off together like into the sunset so
like i said him accepting her
monstrosity
so it's it's kind of like it's i would
actually love to see like a [ __ ]
sequel of this where it's like the two
of them are just going around killing
bad people and you know with with the
little cat like perched in the car and
everything did i say this kind of
reminded me of near dark a little bit
too and i wasn't the only person that
said that because mark carmode from uh
from bbc
like uh he compared it to that too and
also that other catherine bigelow movie
but i can't remember what it's called
right now um but yeah it kind of like
reminded me of that too but it's same
kind of same kind of like crossover
western vampire feel but also
largely a love story so
and very very very gym jar mushy so you
know not a lot of dialogue there are a
lot of like long scenes just just like
visual like cool visual [ __ ] um a lot of
long scenes of just like music but the
music in this is great like the
soundtrack is great like a lot of early
80s like indie kind of stuff uh or at
least influenced by that and then like
some kind of spaghetti westerny sounding
uh music as well and like i said has a
little bit of kind of like a 50s meets
80s
meets
german expressionist kind of vibe to it
so like i said it's almost like this
collage of all this stuff that anna lily
amapor really liked and i thought that
was like a really cool
way to go like i said this is not going
to be for everybody um some people might
just think it's very very slow like i
said stuff does happen in it but it's
not a straight
horror movie it's kind of a it's kind of
an homage to a lot of different things
and
honestly if i had to call it anything i
would say it's almost like a romance
like with some other kind of stuff doing
it but i don't know that seems like
i don't know if i want to say that
either because that might give the wrong
impression it's just a really really
hard movie to
kind of put your finger on but like i
said if you're into like jim jarmusch
type stuff or you know david lynch or
spaghetti western type stuff
and you want to see something along
those lines like in an art house sort of
format then this would probably be right
up your alley so let me know if you've
seen this uh what you think about it and
let me know if you've seen the bad batch
if that's worth watching because i have
actually heard a lot of good stuff about
that i just haven't got around to
watching it yet that's her second movie
by the way
and i really actually do uh want to see
it if it's worth watching but yeah so if
you have not seen this then i would
recommend if you don't have any of the
kind of like streaming services it's
normally on to think it's on 2b for free
at least as of this recording it's also
on shutter pretty sure it's on amazon
prime as well so uh check it out if you
haven't seen it if you have seen it let
me know what you thought about it and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear and i will see you guys on the next
one bye